TO THE PRESIDENT’S DESK ON
FRIDAY WHERE HE WILL SIGN IT
INTO LAW.
>> Ed: HERE IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTION FOR OUR
VIEWERS.
THEY HEAR $2 TRILLION.
BIG NUMBER.
A LOT OF INDUSTRIES WILL BE
HELPED AND NEED IT NOW BUT THE
WORKERS NEED IT MOST.
HOW QUICKLY TO GET OUT THE
CHECKS.
PEOPLE ARE WONDERING ABOUT THE
MONEY FOR FAMILIES.
WE HEAR IT COULD GET WEEKS AND
ARE YOU WORRIED?
HOW QUICKLY CAN PEOPLE GET THE
MONEY?
>> I WAS TOLD TWO TO THREE
WEEKS.
THE BIPARTISAN AGREEMENT IS THE
WORKING MAN NEEDS HELP RIGHT
NOW.
THAT’S WHAT THE DIRECT CHECK
ASSISTANCE IS DESIGNED TO DO.
BUT WE THINK WITHIN A MATTER OF
WEEKS PEOPLE WILL HAVE THE
$1200 FOR CHILDREN 500.
BUT ED, THE MOST IMPORTANT
PROVISION IN MY JUDGMENT IS THE
SMALL BUSINESS LOANS THAT
INVOLVES BOTH LOANS AND TAX
PROVISIONS.
THEY CAN HELP SMALL BUSINESSES
STAY AFLOAT WITH CASH FLOW AND
LIQUIDITY SO THEY DON’T LAY OFF
ALL THE WORKERS.
WE’RE TRYING TO GET THROUGH THE
NEXT 15 DAYS, I SAY TWO MONTHS
REALLY OF A CRISIS WHERE WE CAN
KEEP THEM AFLOAT SO THEY DON’T
GO UNDER SO THAT WHEN WE DO
REBOUND OUT OF THIS CRISIS,
THESE COMPANIES WILL STILL BE
IN EXISTENCE AND THE JOBS WILL
STILL BE THERE AND PEOPLE WILL
NOT BE ON THE STREETS.
WE ALSO HAVE A PANDEMIC
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSISTANCE FOR
THOSE WHO DO NOT QUALIFY UNDER
THAT PROVISION.
AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE THE
WORKING MAN WHOLE.
RIGHT NOW WE WANT TO KEEP THE